viele leute haben mir die kommentare
geschrieben hey luca ist ja schön und
gut dass wir jeden zweiten tag einen
block hoch und es macht auch aber bitte
wieder gaming und was wird da besser
passen als pfeifen heiz- freddys 21
nicht kennt das jetzt unser büro haben
wir können hier licht anmachen an dem
tunnel wir können an diesem turnier
licht anmachen und wir können wenn wir
cdl gedrückt halten die taschenlampe an
machen dann sehen nämlich diesen gang
hier vorne ich klicke einfach mal auf
news corp die sache ist bei 5 912 ich
habe jetzt schon angst er falls es für
die es geht es darum dass wir in einer
pizzeria arbeiten und das ist scheiße
dieses teil 2 habe ich denn überhaupt
schon mal gespielt das sollte aber
eigentlich genau das gleiche prinzip
sein
hier befindet sich gerade niemand wir
können hier rein guckt dann sehen wir
dass hier drei personen schön einmal
dieses dieser bär und noch diese dieser
ente hier wir befinden uns in diesem
kleinen kontrollzentrum und wir müssen
hier kontrollieren dass keine von diesen
tieren hier in die zu uns kommen wenn
wir hier gucken die befinden sich noch
alle in diesem raum kam 09 wir befinden
uns hier unten
die nerven aufreibend die sache ist die
tiere können sich nur bewegen wenn wir
gerade nicht auf diesem raum hier sind
also wir können auch mal einen anderen
raum hier gucken oder in denen hier in
denen hier und wieder in chemnitz ist
ein abgehauen entwarnung es sind noch
alle drei von diesen fächern hier da die
sache ist wir können eigentlich die
ganze zeit in diesem raum bleiben und
uns mit dem mit dem bildschirm sag ich
mal anschauen wie diese drei personen da
hinten sitzen die sache ist allerdings
dass das nicht gehen weil wir mich
unendlich akku haben also wir können uns
jetzt nicht einfach die ganze zeit
diesen raum mir angucken die sache jetzt
auch das zwischendurch einfach mal ein
paar räume ausfallen und man sich die
dann einfach nicht mehr angucken kann
jetzt gerade sieht hier allerdings alles
noch relativ cool aus ankam 09 ist auch
noch jeder das heißt jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen ich hab' ich hasse horror
spiele wie die pest freunde aber gut wir
sind schon bei 2 m
wir müssen bis 7 uhr morgens über leben
und hoffen dass uns diese leute nicht
irgendwie kriegen also hier ist niemand
hier ist niemand und wenn wir mal rechts
gucken ist hier auch noch niemand wir
schauen mal hier es ist so nein nein
nein wo bist du kleiner dreikäsehoch
okay der ist zum glück noch nicht ganz
bei uns also hier ist dieses komische 4
ma lin kämen nur noch oh mein gott der
zweite ist auch beck
mann ich will dich aus diesem spiel raus
gehen da ist jemand ach du scheiße in
meinem keller liegt eine leiche
eingeweckt das ist doch nicht wahr leute
ich kann mir das noch nicht geben
konnten ihren mann der später die ganze
zeit oben kam 07 ist niemand hier steht
immer noch der die sache ist in diesem
tunnel steht dieses komische 405 ist
niemand kam 0 1 1 m da auch nicht auch
nicht hier ist der ehemann der nacht
nummer zwei freunde
wir gehen mal in den raum in ganz hinten
und wir bleiben jetzt mal längere zeit
in diesem raum hier
die sache ist
also wir sind jetzt hier seit mehreren
minuten auf diesem raum irgendwie geht
unsere batterie nicht leer wir sehen
halt hier oben nur flash lite ein
geländer weg sind noch da es ist schon
zwei uhr wir sind das glaube ich gar
nicht so richtig eingeblendet weil da
meine fans kam darüber ist aber das ist
unser flashlight akkustand also komplett
voll und wir haben gar kein richtiges
energielevel für dieses die für diesen
monitor auf dem wir die ganze zeit drauf
gucken das war bei 5 release ist teil
eins nämlich immer der fall erkennt man
sicherheit nicht die ganze zeit auf
diesen monitor stürzen und sich einfach
diese räume anschauen weil dann
irgendwie der akku leer gegangen ddp
soll ich es doch irgendwie was machen
wenn paar sekunden später
achtung schweiz ja wow ein aspekt ok
kult das freut mich ist hier ist er hier
ist ja hier leer wo bist du kleiner
piekser alter zeitlich kaum hatte er das
mache ich ihnen jetzt also hier ist
dieser typ achtung scheiße sieht der
ekelhaft aus ich gehe noch mal in die
kern 09 nach hinten kommt bitte zeigt
mir dass dieses komische figur des
abgehauen kommt lasst mich in ruhe ich
will das nicht spielen ich will ist ich
will dieses spiel eigentlich gar nicht
spielen aber es haben wir so viele leute
in die kommentare geschrieben von wegen
lukas spieler mal wieder ein horror
spiel also gut da kommen mag ich mal weg
hier ist er hier hinten irgendwo ne da
ist niemand ist hier nach da kommt eine
es ist zumindest doch keiner ganz nah
bei mir du bist immer noch ein ehrenmann
lieber teddy lucic vorne einfach rum
hier ist niemand hier ist niemand da ist
auch niemand hier ist niemand da ist
niemand
ihr wollt ihr mich verarschen
wo sind die denn alle
das soll in diesem masse jetzt
macht man sich ja dieses spiel
[Musik]